ahora que hemos hablado de la boca en
general pongamos una sonrisa en esa cara
y observemos los dientes con un poco más
de profundidad lo que tenemos aquí es
una imagen del hueso inferior otro
término para el hueso inferior es
mandíbula esta es tu mandíbula y este es
el lado izquierdo de tu mandíbula así
que escribiré izquierda y este es el
lado derecho para que puedas seguirnos
mientras hablamos de tus dientes como
puedes ver las cosas son bastante
simétricas cierto puedo dibujar una
línea divisoria hacia abajo por el
centro y a medida que avanzamos y
hablamos de cada pequeño diente que
tenemos veremos que tenemos el mismo
diente no solo en el otro lado sino
también en tu maxilar también conocido
como hueso maxilar para este diente
tenemos una imagen de espejo aquí y para
este par hay dos en el maxilar tener eso
en cuenta mientras revisamos esto y
cuando hagamos los cálculos al final
cada diente o cada conjunto de dientes
tienen una función específica veamos los
diferentes tipos de dientes que tenemos
este que tenemos aquí se llama incisivo
central incisivo central nuevamente
tenemos cuatro incisivos centrales en
total tenemos el que he señalado aquí el
segundo aquí y luego otros dos en el
maxilar el incisivo central se utiliza
principalmente para cortar este es el
diente que usas para cortar la comida la
forma de recordar eso es la razón por la
que llamamos a estos dientes incisivos
como en cirugía decimos que estamos a
punto de hacer una incisión es decir
estamos a punto de hacer un corte de
modo que los incisivos centrales hacen
incisiones lo mismo sucede cuando
hablamos de los incisivos laterales
tenemos cuatro en total al igual que los
incisivos centrales sólo hay uno de este
lado así que escribiré cuatro en total
también se usan para cortar la comida
ahora que hemos hablado sobre los
incisivos pasemos a hablar de los
caninos
este es nuestro diente canino y tenemos
cuatro de ellos en total el diente
canino también se conoce como colmillo
y verás porque lo mostraré en otra
imagen son los dientes más afilados y
largos que tenemos y en realidad se usan
para agarrar son para agarrar puedes
imaginar cuando vas a un restaurante y
al principio te dan una cesta de pan
pones un pedazo de pan en la boca y
tiras de él para desgarrar lo porque tus
cuatro dientes caninos están sujetando
el pan en la boca mientras con la mano
tiras del resto así que pondré tirar
aquí solo como una pequeña indicación de
cómo usamos nuestros caninos ahora que
hemos terminado con nuestros caninos a
continuación podemos hablar sobre
nuestros premolares tenemos dos
premolares en cada lado lo que significa
que en total tenemos ocho de ellos
tenemos ocho premolares y veremos en dos
partes lo que hacen primero si ves la
palabra mola por aquí es una referencia
a la palabra latina mola lo que
significa moler en realidad representa
una piedra de molino
si alguna vez observas una piedra de
molino o una muela
mamola en latín y eso tiene sentido
porque nuestros dientes premolares se
usan para moler nuestra comida mientras
la mastica moss la otra cosa a tener en
cuenta es esta primera parte de la
palabra pre los llamamos pre porque
estos dos dientes premolares están antes
que estos tres dientes molares finales
entonces tenemos tres dientes molares
aquí lo que significa que tenemos un
gran total de 12 dientes al igual que
los premolares estos están aquí también
para moler para romper nuestra comida
mientras la mastica moss es la misma
raíz latina que discutimos anteriormente
ahora que hemos hablado de los
diferentes tipos de dientes es
interesante que sólo el 28 por ciento de
la población tiene la mandíbula como en
esta imagen del libro de texto por qué
pasa eso aquí tengo una bonita imagen
panorámica tal vez puedes reconocer a
alguien familiar cuya imagen fue tomada
aquí y se ve muy bien
este es el lado derecho y este es el
lado izquierdo en realidad esto es una
radiografía panorámica de mi mirando
hacia ti es una vista de frente y como
ahora los conoces los incisivos
centrales y estos son los incisivos
centrales en mi mandíbula como
referencia este hueso superior que
contiene la parte superior también se
conoce como maxilar entonces por qué no
aclaramos esto este de aquí arriba es mi
maxilar y como ya sabes esta es mi
mandíbula escribiré mandíbula por aquí
lo interesante es que cuando miras los
dientes que tengo aquí hay algo
diferente de la imagen que vimos
anteriormente y es porque si los cuentas
aquí está mi incisivo central este es mi
incisivo lateral el canino este es mi
primer premolar este es mi segundo
premolar este es mi primer molar y este
es mi segundo molar aquí falta algo y no
sólo aquí sino que en realidad falta en
este lado en este lado y en este lado
creo que lo has adivinado no están mis
cuatro terceros molares
razones porque eran mis muelas del
juicio los terceros molares se llaman
muelas del juicio y a menudo las
personas se las quitan de hecho el 72
por ciento de las personas la saca el 72
por ciento de nuestra población se quitó
las muelas del juicio en realidad hay
una explicación bastante simple de por
qué ocurre eso si miras las encías que
tengo aquí solo voy a hacer un dibujo
aproximado de mis encías e intentaré
asegurarme de excluir mis dientes
mientras hago este pequeño dibujo por
aquí si miras las encías que están
rodeando cada diente que tengo en mi
mandíbula tienen suficiente espacio para
que salga cada diente déjame colorear
eso la forma en que sale el diente es
que hay un pequeño agujero designado
para eso déjame dibujar una aquí para mi
segundo molar quiero dibujar uno aquí
para mi incisivo lateral así que ese es
el agujero del incisivo lateral que
emergió el agujero para el tercer molar
a veces termina siendo bastante pequeño
en el 72% de las personas termina siendo
bastante pequeño
problema es que cuando mi tercer molar
está aquí déjame dibujar este tercer
molar y quiere salir naturalmente lo que
quieres ver que suceda es que el tercer
molar pase por este camino y luego salga
a través de este agujero
desafortunadamente esto no es lo que
sucede en la mayoría de las personas el
tercer molar comúnmente intenta hacer
erupción a través de la encía de latín
gingival que es un término importante lo
escribiré abajo si tratan de hacer
erupción a través de la encía pueden
tener inflamación o desgarro de esta o
incluso una infección si ocurre por un
periodo prolongado
esto sucede comúnmente en personas
dentro del grupo de edad de 17 a 25 años
aproximadamente
por eso las llamamos muelas del juicio
cuando ganan un poco de sabiduría los
cuatro terceros molares comienzan a
erupcionar a través de la encía es
deseable eliminarlos antes de tener
alguna mala reacción como inflamación o
infección que puede estropear los
dientes vecinos que han crecido bien es
genial si puedes reconocer esto
porque ahora puedes leer e interpretar
por ti mismo la misma radiografía que
usó mi dentista para ver que me
extrajeron las muelas del juicio de
forma correcta y segura